[Musique]
c'est l'heure de se la péter ou de la
boucle est très bons films en tout cas
dans la continuité du premier donc
beaucoup d'humour et vraiment je suis
ravi c'est drôle j'ai déjà vu le premier
alors dix ans se sont écoulés depuis
l'apocalypse zombie cette famille
dysfonctionnelle joyeux noël tu veux
savoir ce que j'aimerais je m'en
contrefous deux de ces prêts a survécu
en faisant preuve de discernement
radu et pour la survie
allez encore en vie parce que les
zombies se nourrissent que certaines
écoles à rien les personnages sont hyper
sympa c'est pas trop grand pour les
enfants et ben non mais c'est les
dialogues qui sont rigolos les
situations c'est démarrant mais ça fait
pas non plus trop peur et bas les
personnages y sont attachants ouais
vieux monsieur est tout petit il n'est
plus là il est les voies celui-là ça ne
fait pas peur non non c'est bon on est
un peu de gore comme parce que c'est un
film de zombies mais c'est très très
très drôle à la fois on pense que c'est
sérieux mais non ce n'est pas du tout
sérieux c'est vraiment de la déconne
jusqu'à la fin
dix ans dix ans
[Musique]